all right look good hi I'm Greg hi I'm
amber amber from the amber Platzer
channel yes and she also does videos
live on Harry of the hot periscope and
part of actors buzz I'm on periscope I
do live streaming on periscope and I
also am one of the hosts on afterbuzz TV
and I read a new TV shows on afterbuzz
TV the YouTube channel it's a really
awesome channel if you're into TV shows
and she actually does some reactions on
her channel there's just these awesome
reviews of Star Wars first time watch
them and they're great videos on there
she's very intelligent and very funny
thank you you have to be funny today now
that I said that I will do my goddamn
bed um I said that I have a Star Wars
react series on my youtube channel where
I just realized that one of the hosted
afterbuzz TV and we both have never seen
Star Wars and we were like oh let's
watch it because we want to watch the
force awakens but then we thought we
can't just wash the photo anyway and
without knowing everything else about it
so that's how I kind of fell into
reaction if you're going to do research
you might as well have a camera
recording myself
oh yeah now get some views out of that
conversation if I'm in assisted a
prequel you guys aren't exactly pirates
of the caribbean dead men tell no tales
this reaction is late mix two reasons
one my camera broke so I have to borrow
a camera at the very last minute to I
wanted to make sure I did a video with
amber that would get some views
you never know any ones we get views
that's so goddamn considerate I feel
like I really hope this is a really good
or really terrible trick yeah to get
some kind of reaction happy mediocre I
will not be happy I'm sure it's going to
be Fanta okay well with rum
[Music]
pirate atoms fit the disease for
generations only love him with me Javier
Mario eliminate them and then there was
this boy
what the hell
another actor he took everything from me
[Music]
reach whoa
are we getting a vision but mister the
piracy care of you captain they've come
to be thousands of men is been using
something Spanish title ship the crew
[Music]
your parents just to check out a pan
sorry we still talking
[Applause]
[Music]
considering why you're not happy but
they were wolves not
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
you pay for what you did to me
[Music]
Wow crazy
[Music]
thanks putting four three stop no no
this is one far enough no it macaque
I thought her ankles get this thing a
lot more of you can't deny Kolchak
Wow I stopped her ankle they're getting
naughty with their favor Jimmy's getting
naughty
oh my god me whoa that was more than I
was expecting and also why is he so
young-looking is this a prequel well no
that was a flashback he's explaining why
Javier Bardem turned into who he is now
that's like weird-looking Spanish I mean
he always looks banished but it'd be I
don't know weird skeleton looking thing
that he kind of looks like now
so he's been your villain I mean when I
felt when I saw the other teaser
trailers for this I felt like okay this
plot seems a little on repeat there's a
pirate out there who hates Jack Sparrow
and wants is Pharaoh - yeah yeah coming
for a chef coming again she actually
acts on the run again probably have to
do something for him but watching this I
was like okay this is interesting first
when I saw the other teaser trailers for
this I felt like okay this plot seems a
little on repeat there's a pirate out
there who hates Jack Sparrow and watch
Jack Sparrow - yeah yeah coming for any
ship coming in to act on the run again
probably have to do something for him
watching this I was like okay this is
interesting first we're getting a
flashback in the beginning of this
trailer the other parts of the Caribbean
movies only allude to the Past how much
trouble he got it yeah and here they're
actually showing you like here's a young
jack and here's something he actually
did so it surprisingly makes this one
feel a lot more personal which I like I
like I feeling like oh this seems like
it could feel more I don't know
inclusive necessary owning that work for
it I would love to see Jack's backstory
even if we already know it because of
less responsible Jack Sparrow is only
more attractive to me exactly exactly I
just want to see him mess up right I
don't know why that character I just
love to see Meza that's the best part of
Jack Sparrow
but it looks prettier than really
harkens back to the first one yes in
good ways and also I don't know how I
feel about the two young characters
basically being like Miss Swan menu
Orlando Bloom Akira died yeah how
awkward cinema they weren't invited back
well I think we're Lana Bloom's back in
this I think we found briefly in another
trailer I don't know a Knightley's not
back yeah she's not doing but I know
Orlando Bloom is supposed to be in this
one too I would watch this [ __ ] out of
it this looks like a really fantastic
time the action sequences look great the
humor actually looks like it could be
funny because I don't know if you saw on
Stranger Tides you see the fourth one I
didn't let see the fourth one but I've
seen it once retreat oh yeah one two and
three
I like one and two a lot action cam I
once one of my favorite movies of all
time 1 & 2 c'mere both very rewatchable
yeah definitely part 3 I don't like I
hated part 4 but this seems to go back
to more about making it just a fun
adventure piratey filled film instead of
going like I don't know exactly I
haven't seen the fourth one in years
and the third one was just so dark and
serious and it wasn't fun at all yeah do
you read it when every film ever tries
to to Dark Knight it yeah I feel like
every franchise tends to do that with
their sequel hey we're gonna go dirt or
with me gonna go to your car yeah or you
could not if it doesn't make sense for
your story well I feel like part 2 of
Pirates even goes darker but it still is
a lot of five you like the first time
you watch it you might be thrown off but
the second time I watched it I thought
it was great the third one I just can't
get on board with in the fourth one I
just being is a total snoozefest I've
heard only nothing yeah I mean over a
billion dollars shocking being like the
money grab so like I get it it seemed
like Johnny Depp didn't care to be there
to join up looks like it's giving it at
all Johnny just looks clocked yeah it's
like this is the Jack I've been waiting
for again just in the last one I was
like you just seem like you don't give a
[ __ ] anymore
looking at the bits of footage here it
looks like he's having a really good
time and he looks like he wants to be a
part of this movie well he does he's
single now yesterday now so maybe he's
like oh I should pay attention to my
career now maybe you weren't clocked in
and writer that's what this is about
yeah that was about what get laid
why he actually gives a [ __ ] what I'm
saying is he should call me it's fine
but even harkening back to the first one
like think about it new Orlando Bloom
has to break out Jack Sparrow from jail
mhm and that he wants to go save this
girl who was really into who doesn't
seem like she's quite reciprocating
again or maybe they have an unspoken
romance or they're just not saying to
each other that they really want to have
sex with each other and so it doesn't
seem very much into it even like the
villains to kind of echo more of the
skeleton villains because they kind of
look like a zombie pirates in a way and
similar to you know she takes off her
corset and jumps in the water Keira
Knightley jumps in the water and Jackie
mr. corces yeah drown she cannot drown
it's very it's very throwback II yeah
the monkeys back you got he can't do the
movie without the monkey look it was
really cute the monkey is very cute even
the sets look very similar to the first
one yeah almost more kid-friendly almost
mortgage that's a great way to put it
because I felt like as I kept going they
kept getting more for like adults but
with like bad writing so it's like this
felling that we're looking at a l'heure
kids and adults so it felt like darker
more mature but with kid writing yeah
here it feels like they actually know
what they're doing with the tone in the
style here and I just love that the
villain actually seems like this is more
than just talking about the past it
feels like it's something actually
personal I don't know if in the
beginning that is young Johnny Depp or
like he really a Johnny Depp it looks
like it could be joined up good even
freaky oh yeah it did the whole like the
Marvel turning them younger or face eg
right yeah it has to be CG I don't think
that's a different it looks like young
Johnny Depp but it's totally they did
the whole like me you know what it skins
a little bit too shiny oh no yes totally
off have all these other crazy lighting
things going on to try to like to
stretch you from Alice yeah but it's I
don't know if it'll work I thought it
was an actor though for a second yeah
it's hard to tell I can't tell
and what was weirded out when they do
CGI things hippies always tell because
you've been always told with yeah you'll
be watching and you'll be like what's
wrong with ya no matter how good it
looks yeah
yeah fellas take it off and then it's
tracks you from the last two minutes
and then you're out yeah looks like me I
like to think I look like a young Johnny
Depp
wait furrow your brow was on yeah like
this like he's doing what you're doing
yeah yeah you bet totally under the same
face we're the same thing yeah I don't
know how you're reducing it
you use need a bandana this is a bad
name of the Jamaican braids yeah get rid
of the curls lose the facial hair yeah
let's get a facelift thanks and then
I'll look like Johnny Depp yeah just
work on that by the time we view our
next video that was great
all right guys well that was a really
cool trailer I'm glad you were here to
watch it with me and speaking of amber
you should just desert the dead outro
YouTube videos you should subscribe you
can subscribe to the real reject amber
plasters channel not amber her channel
there's a reason Johnny Depp did
something to her yeah amber plush her
yeah something like a good domestic
violence Joe Hurley don't remind me I
never heard and I want to have to go
there it's fine we just have fun here we
just have fun there was no audio or
video so my neighbors are telling the
truth right on mobiusman but it's same
amber placer channel go check her out
seriously she has great content on there
she's really funny have good opinions
good insight you know how to connect
with the camera oh thank you can
subscribe to the real rejects and shout
out any shape to the youtuber cleanse 80
the first one who requested this thank
you there's a little comment at the
bottom yeah appreciate you being a lot
of people request with its course but
you were the first one who actually put
in a comment so you get it slim what is
your Johnny just like
dialogue with your go-to droid death
sentence okay my god you guys attended
yeah when I first read the screenplay
for Ringo oh that's it
halfway through this group that I
realized I'm bleeding the lizard and
from there the character just sort of
evolved the end
that's it Lucy's my whole Johnny Depp is
just how I can I can never say something
very philosophical but it never turns
out to be the hope of it again